Schön.
Okay.
Guten Abend.
Der hier ist mein Name.
Ich bin der WDSA, Ben-Daerts auf dieser Station.
Wie heißen Sie?
Ich heiße Josefine Renner.
Könnt ihr bitte Ihre Nachname langsam bestabilen?
Ja, der Vornamen ist Josefine.
J-O-S-E-F-I-N-E.
Ja, Josefine.
Josefine.
Und der Familienname ist Renner.
R-E-N-E-R.
Renner.
Wie jemand, der schnell läuft.
Ja, Frau Renner.
Was kann ich für Sie tun, Frau Renner?
Was führt Sie so?
Ja, also, wissen Sie, ich habe heute Morgen,
fing das an, dass ich solche,
solchen Druck hier auf der Brust habe, ja.
Und das hat angefangen, heute Morgen,
ja, ich habe mich gestritten mit meinen Nachbarn
und habe mich ein bisschen aufgeregt.
Und mit allem fing das an,
dass ich solche heftigen Schmerzen machte.
Und puh, ich hatte dann das Gefühl,
dass ich gar nicht gut Luft kriege.
Und ja, dann, die Schmerzen drückten so ganz fest
auf die Brust hier oben, ja.
Ja.
Ich habe dann eine Schmerzverblätte genommen,
aber das hat mir eigentlich nicht geholfen.
Und dann dachte ich, ja, so, vielleicht ist das gut.
Ich habe dann noch ein bisschen auf und hatte noch mal frische Luft ein.
Aber dann hatte ich mit einmal das Gefühl,
durch die Kälte, dass es noch schlechter wird.
Ja, und ich meine, jetzt inzwischen ist es deutlich besser.
Aber ich habe wirklich große Angst gehabt.
Ja, dann, ja, schließlich habe ich das dann,
habe ich das dann meinem Sohn erzählt
und der hat gesagt am Telefon, ne?
Mensch, fahr mal ins Krankenhaus und lass dich da mal untersuchen.
Ja, Sie haben gut gemacht, Frau Renna.
Gerade haben Sie noch Schmerzen?
Also es ist jetzt besser, aber das waren wirklich sehr,
sehr heftige Schmerzen.
Sehr heftige Schmerzen.
Sind Strahlende Schmerzen in Ihren Kohlen aus?
Ja, was ganz komisch war,
dass das also hier bis in den,
so als ob man es Schmerzen hat, ja,
so wie hier eingestrahlt hat
und auch so ein bisschen in den Arm rein.
Ja, in der linken Arm.
Ja, genau.
Die linken Arm.
Frau Renna, ich möchte unsere Gespräche kurz unterbrechen
und möchte Ihre Vital-Szeichen überprüft von
und ich möchte auch die EKG schreiben.
Wenn alles in Ordnung ist,
dann werde ich unsere Gespräche wieder weitermachen.
Okay, gut.
Okay.
Ja, Frau Renna,
Ihr habt Ihre Vital-Szeichen und EKG kontrolliert.
Alles sieht in Ordnung.
Nein, in Ordnung.
Ich weiß nicht.
In der Zwischenzeit können wir unsere Gespräche vorsetzen.
Okay.
Kein richtig Wortgeber, ja, okay.
Ja, okay.
Ja.
Und Frau Renna,
wie stark sind die Schmerzen auf einer Schmerzgala,
wobei ein sehr lecker Schmerzen
und zehn sehr starker Schmerzen entstehen?
Ja, sehr stark.
Das war schon sehr stark eine Schmerz.
Jetzt ist es ja nicht mehr so schlimm,
aber ja,
vielleicht nicht ganz unerträglich,
aber es war schon so etwas,
das einem sehr viel Angst gemacht hat.
Vielleicht so bei acht oder so.
Achts, ja.
Haben Sie ein Gefühl, wer merkt?
Ja, ja, also ich, wie gesagt,
ich habe so diesen Druck gehabt auf der Brust.
Ja.
Und mir war auch richtig schlecht.
Und ich hatte auch das Gefühl, ich kann nicht gut erraten, ja.
Ja, okay.
Okay.
Und haben Sie Schweiß-Ei aus Brüche?
Nein, das habe ich eigentlich nicht.
Okay.
Und haben Sie Übelkeit?
Was habe ich?
Haben Sie Übelkeit?
Übelkeit? Ja.
Ja, das sagte ich ja gerade.
Das ist mir eigentlich schlecht, also jetzt nicht mehr,
aber vorhin war mir richtig schlecht, ja.
Richtig schlecht.
Mussten Sie übergeben?
Nein, nein, nein.
Und haben Sie ähnliche Beschwerde?
Ja, wo Sie jetzt danach fragen, fällt mir das ein.
Vor, das ist nicht lange her.
Da habe ich das mal gehabt, aber also nicht so stark,
als ich ein paar Treppen hoch gelaufen bin,
da war der aufzukaput.
Und ich musste halt in die zweite Etage, dritte Etage hoch.
Und Puh, da habe ich gedacht, ich muss stehen bleiben.
Und weil ich auch so dieses Gefühl hatte,
dass da mit einem so ganz starker Druck ist, ja.
Starker Druck.
Aber da das dann nachher wieder weg ist,
habe ich gedacht, ach, hast du dich vertan, ne?
Manchmal passiert diese Beschwerde.
Aber ich denke mal, das ist ungefähr so 2, 3 Wochen her.
Ja, ja.
2, 3 Wochen.
Okay.
Frau Renner, wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 51.
51.
Wann sind Sie genau geworden?
Am 8., 7., 73.
17.
Okay.
Frau Renner, sind Sie für diese Beschwerde beim Arzt gewesen?
Nein, damals habe ich gedacht, ich bin wieder weggegangen
und dann bin ich da nicht hingegangen.
Ja, okay.
Sind die Schmerzen dauerhaft oder gehen Sie wieder weg?
Wenn zum Glück ist das ja wieder weggegangen, ja.
Wieder weg, ja.
Haben Sie Fieber oder grünen Sie sich Pipi?
Ja, also das eigentlich nicht.
Ich habe nur diese, diese schäftigen Schmerzen,
diese drückenden Schmerzen gehabt.
Ja, die Schmerzen.
Haben die Probleme beim Wasserlassen oder mit dem Stuhlgang?
Ja, normalerweise.
Ich gehe häufiger mal nachts auf die Toilette,
aber sonst eigentlich nix, nee.
In der Nacht gehen Sie?
Ja, manchmal muss ich einmal in der Nacht,
selten auch zweimal, wenn ich früh schlafen gehe,
muss ich in der Nacht auf die Toilette gehen.
Seit wann, ob Sie in der Nacht auf die Toilette gehen?
Ach, das ist schon, ja, vielleicht seit einem Jahr ungefähr.
Gibt es Probleme mit dem Stuhlgang?
Nein, eigentlich nicht.
Frau Renner, schlafen Sie gut?
Nicht so sehr gut.
Nicht so sehr.
Und hat sich Ihr Gewicht in der letzten Zeit verändert,
haben Sie ab und zu genommen?
Nein, das ist leider immer gleich, ja.
Immer gleich.
Wie viel legen Sie?
87 kg.
Wie groß sind Sie?
1,73.
1,3,70.
Ist Ihnen Stahlforst-Machtschweiß aufgefallen?
Nee.
Sieht bei Ihnen, welcher Erkrankung derkannt,
ich meine Blutdruck-Skull-Krankheit oder Schichtdrüsse?
Leider, leider, ja.
Also ich habe ein bisschen hohen Blutdruck, ja.
Vor vier Jahren hat man auch festgestellt,
dass ich diesen Alferzucker habe.
Und dann nehme ich halt Metformin morgens und abends
und gegen den Blutdruck nehme ich eben auch Tabletten ein, ja.
Welche Tag nehmen Sie?
Dann nehme ich Ramek Friedl ein.
Dann nehme ich morgens eine Tablette.
Und Zuckerkrankheit wird auch vor vier Jahren festgestellt.
Vor vier Jahren war das, ja, genau.
Gibt es noch andere Erkrankungen?
Ja, vor ein paar Monaten hat mein Haus also mal Blutfettwerte,
bestimmt die Waren wohl ein bisschen höher.
Aber eigentlich versuche ich ja auch ein bisschen vorsichtig
zu essen wegen der Diabeteserkrankung.
Und deswegen haben wir da jetzt noch keine Tabletten dagegen genommen.
Sie machen nur Diets, sehr.
Er versuche das mit Diets ein bisschen ein bisschen einzuschränken, ja.
Sind bei Ihnen Allergien bekannt?
Nicht, dass ich wüsste, ich glaube,
nicht, dass ich auf irgendwas Allergis bin.
Okay. Wussten Sie schon mal, ob er geht?
Ja, die Gebärmutter ist mehr entfernt worden.
Das ist jetzt fünf Jahre her, ja.
Gibt es noch andere Operation?
Nee, sonst habe ich bisher in meinem Leben noch keine Operation gehabt.
Okay. Brauchen Sie?
Ja, ja, ja. Also, ich kann es immer noch nicht lassen.
Früher habe ich 20 Zigaretten am Tag geraucht,
aber jetzt sind es nur noch zehn, aber ja, ich rauche schon viel, ja.
Seit wann?
Ja, dann habe ich angefangen, so mit 20,
dann habe ich früher richtig viel geraucht
und dann habe ich das ein bisschen reduziert.
Als mein Sohn auf die Welt kam,
da habe ich dann mal für eine Weile ganz wenig nur geraucht,
über fast gar nicht und dann habe ich es aber später wieder angefangen.
Ja, darf ich fragen, seid ihr reduziert?
Ja, ich würde sagen, so vor 20 Jahren habe ich das mal reduziert
und dann habe ich aber nach zehn Jahren wieder angefangen.
Trinkt ihr Alkohol?
Und wieder trinke ich meinen Glas Wein, ja, das trinke ich schon auf deine Wein.
Wein? Wie viel trinken Sie?
Vielleicht mal am Wochenende oder wenn es etwas zu feiern gibt
oder trinke ich meinen Glas Wein
oder stoße auch mal an mit einem Glas Sekt oder so,
aber nicht regelmäßig.
Ich nehme an, dass Sie keine Drogen nehmen, oder?
Nee, früher habe ich mal, ja, in der wilden Jugend,
da habe ich mal, in meinem Haschist probiert,
ja, mit der Hocherei, aber ja, das ist mir nicht gut bekommen,
dann habe ich das wirklich nur ganz selten gemacht.
Ja, ist schön.
Frau Röner, haben Ihre Eltern eventuell schon Erkrankungen?
Das sind Sie mir überlegen, meine Mutter ist eigentlich, ich kärngesund.
Mein Vater weiß ich, also, der ist relativ früh verstorben
und ich meine, der hatte tatsächlich herzlichen Erkrankungen
und ich habe mich dann auch schon erzielt.
Der ist relativ früh verstorben
und ich meine, der hatte tatsächlich Herzprobleme, ja.
Weil, weil, wann ist er gestorben und woran?
Also, ich meine, der hätte ihn in Farb gehabt
und der ist also 72 gewesen.
72.
Weil, weil, haben Sie jetzt Schwester?
Nee, Geschwister habe ich nicht, wie ich war Einzelkind.
Sind Sie verheiratet, Frau Röner?
Ich bin geschieben.
Geschieben.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Weil, ich habe ja einen Sohn, ne?
Ist er gesund?
Er ist gesund, ja, ja, aber er ist natürlich schon aus dem Haus, ne?
Ja.
Was machen Sie beruflich?
Ja, ich bin Hausmeisterin in einem, in einem Bürokomplex.
Büro, Hausmeisterin.
Mhm.
Haben Sie Stress bei der Arbeit?
Ja, da geht es schon manchmal ziemlich stressig zu, ja.
Ich muss immer gucken, dass alles in Ordnung ist
und ja, ständig sind irgendwelche Probleme
und dann funktioniert der Fahrstuhl nicht
und dann muss man den Service anrufen
und keiner hat Zeit, ja, alle wollen immer alles sofort haben.
Da hat er schon Stress dabei.
Ja, Frau Röner, ich möchte unsere Gebetchen kurz zusammenversenden.
Sie haben seit heute Morgen sehr starke Brustschmerzen
und drückende Schmerzen
und auch Duftprobleme, Atemnot
und Schmerzenstrahlen in den Hals und in den Linken an.
Ja, und Sie haben auch Naunsh-, auch Überkeit.
Und warte, Sie, ich habe für mich...
Noch mal?
Ja, Sie haben seit heute Morgen drückende Brustschmerzen...
Nee, nur das letzte, das letzte hatte ich nicht,
aber Sie haben auch Überkeit.
Überkeit, ja.
Ich habe für mich alle wichtige Fragen gestellt.
Möchtest du etwas hinzufügen?
Na ja, natürlich.
Was kann man machen, damit es nicht wiederkommt?
Das ist ja schon ein unangenehmer Zustand
und mir natürlich sehr viel Angst gemacht.
Ich habe natürlich auch ein bisschen in meinem Vater gedacht,
oh, so war es das jetzt, ne?
Und ja, also ich bin wüsste halt schon gerne,
was wir jetzt tun können, da geben.
Ja, ich verstehe Ihre Wagen während Ab.
Aber etwas so, es ist so, etwas genau zu sagen.
Zuerst muss ich sie körperlich unterrufen,
dann muss ich sie körperlich unterrufen.
Ich habe mich alle Fragen gefragt,
damit ich sie weiter überprüfen kann.
Okay, ja.
Ich habe sie unterrufen,
und ich habe sie körperlich unterrufen.
Okay.
Ja, ich habe Fragen.
Sind Sie schon wechseljahrain?
Ja, dadurch durch die Beermutterentfernung, ja.
Ja, okay.
Ich habe auch eine Frage.
Ihre frühe Episode, wie lange hat es damals gedauert?
Können Sie erinnern?
Ja, das war ganz kurz nur, das war ein kleiner Augenblick, also wenige Minuten oder vielleicht nur ein, zwei Minuten oder so.
Jetzt vor diesen Beschwerden heute, hatten Sie etwas einer Belastung gehabt oder waren Sie in Ruhe?
Na, ich war körperlich zwar in Ruhe, aber ich habe mich aufgeregt, ich hatte ja einen Streit.
Und wie lange können Sie anschätzen, dass es gedauert ist?
Ich hatte das Gefühl, das dauert ewig, das ist überhaupt nicht besser geworden.
Ich glaube, sonst wäre ich auch nicht ins Krankenhaus gekommen.
Aber jetzt hatte ich das Gefühl, dass das wirklich lange angedauert hat.
Ich habe aber nicht auf die Uhr geguckt, ich kann nicht sagen, das hat tatsächlich eine halbe Stunde gedauert oder so.
Ich weiß es nicht, wahrscheinlich war es nur auf eine Viertelstunde oder zehn Minuten oder so, aber es kam mir ewig vor.
Okay, verstanden, danke.
Ich glaube, dass Sie eine Frage überlegen, können Sie uns auch ein paar Fragen stellen?
Ja, natürlich.
Bitte schön.
Guten Abend Frau Ersten.
Ich habe einen neuen Patienten aufgenommen.
Frau, Sie sitzen, Renna, es ist ein 50-jähriger Patientin.
Sie kamen zu uns wegen seitholter Mauern bestehender Druck- und Torachschmerz.
Und die Patienten gibt an, dass sie auch Atemnot und Todesangst haben.
Die Schmerzen sind unter den Kiffer und in den Linken.
Die Schmerzen liegen bei 8 von 10 auf einer Schmerzskala.
Die Patienten berichtet, dass sie Ende gefühlt und Mausen haben.
Und der Zweiteren erzählt, dass die Patienten die Schmerzen nach einer emotionalen Belastung aufgetreten sind.
Und außerdem erzählt die Patienten, dass sie vor zwei, drei Wochen ähnliche Bescheide haben.
Gehabt hat?
Gehabt hat, ne?
Gehabt hat, ja.
Wir gehen jetzt in die Anamnese.
Anamnese ist bis auf Nuktturi und Disoni unauffällig.
An der Vorerkrankungen sind arterialen Berthoni, die mit Meletus und Hyperkonstellung nehmen.
Die Patienten nimmt seit vier Jahren Rami Pril einmal morgens und seit vier Jahren mit Formin einmal morgens und einmal abends ein.
Und wegen Hyperkulostrinämie nimmt die Patient keine Medikamenten ein.
Sie macht Diet.
Die Allergen sind nicht bekannt.
Vor fünf Jahren wurde Historoktomie vorgenommen.
Die Patientin braucht täglich Seinsigaretten, aber früher braucht sie 20 Zigaretten.
Die Patientin trägt ein Glas Wein, ein Sech am Wochenende.
Die Patientin hat die Patientin als Jung probiert, aber zurzeit hat sie keine Drohren nehmen.
Als junge Frau hat sie die Drohren probiert.
Meine Familie hat ihrer Vater im Alter 72 Jahre an Merkart-Enfactus gestorben.
Ihre Mutter ist gesund und die Patientin ist einzeln geheim.
Sie ist geschieden und hat einen gesunden Sohn.
Die Patientin ist Hausmeisterin von Beuch.
Um meine Verdachtdiagnose zu bestätigen, würde ich folgende Massnahmen rufstürmen.
Sie haben eine körperliche Untersuchung.
Ich höre Herzschlag und die Lunge.
Ich messe Blutdruck und ich werde auch Puls überprüfen, kontrollieren.
Bei der Labelversuchung würde ich Blutbild, CRP, BSC und Herz-Enzyme treten.
Ich würde auch Röntgen, Torachs in zwei Ebenen veranlassen.
Ich habe eine Ökokardiografie veranlassen.
Wenn ich das bestätige, geben Sie die Patientin für eine Therapieempfehlung?
Ja, sollte sich die Verdacht auf Angene Pektoris erharten, würde ich folgende Therapie empfehlen.
Ich würde die Patientin stationär aufnehmen und Antikorabulant Therapie einleiten.
Ich würde auch Betaglöco anordnen.
Wenn ich bei der Coronagyro-Psy eine Stenosis bestimmen, würde ich Stentherapie oder Biopass Therapie empfehlen.
Was empfehlen Sie der Patientin hinsichtlich Lebensstil?
Ich empfehle Nikotin Abstanz und Alkohol.
Die Patientin ist auch Adipositas.
Ich würde auch Gewicht reduzieren empfehlen.
Ich empfehle die Patientin.
Ich bin gespannt, welche Ergebnisse Sie haben.
Sie haben eine sehr schöne Anamnese gemacht.
Sie haben am Anfang nicht gleich mit den Personalien gewünscht.
Sie haben vergessen, ob sie ein anderes Konzept haben.
Sie haben auch ein anderes Konzept.
Sie haben das einzige, das man machen kann.
Sie haben die Patientin mit Namen angesprochen.
Manchmal waren sie schwer verständlich.
Es liegt nicht am Tempo, dass sie so schnell reden, dass ich es nicht verstehen konnte.
Vielleicht werden sie so engagiert sprechen, dass es dann ein bisschen undeutlich wird.
Das war die Hauptsache im Anamnese-Gespräch.
Beim Art-Arts-Gespräch ist mir aufgefallen, dass sie sehr häufig viele machen.
Ich habe überlegt, ob ich sie unterbrechen soll.
Ich glaube, ich hätte ihren Vortrag völlig durcheinander gebracht.
Hat Vater mit Alter von 72 Jahren gestorben?
Das ist eines der wenigen Ausnahmewörter.
Ich habe nicht mit Alter von 72 Jahren gestorben.
Dann ist mir noch eine Winzigkeit aufgefallen.
Die Allergien sind nicht bekannt.
Im Art-Arts-Gespräch haben sie 2 Diabetes-Meditus gesagt, aber nicht Typ 2.
Das hat sich zwar logischerweise ergeben, weil sie das mit dem Med-Farm-Methy-Nahe gesagt haben,
aber eigentlich muss man es dazu sagen.
Vorankrankung leidet die Patientin, an der die Diabetes-Meditus Typ 2.
Das war es aber auch.
Wenn ich nicht falsch verstanden habe,
diese Beschwerden bestehen oder jetzt momentan keine beschwerden?
Aktuell keine beschwerden, ja.
Sie haben heute Morgen nicht mehr aufgetreten.
Ja, richtig.
Sie haben nicht heute Morgen, sondern vor mehreren Stunden aufgetreten.
Und da auch präventive Schmerzen.
Aber jetzt ist die Schmerzattacke vorbei.
Das ist noch wichtig vom zeitlichen Ablauf.
Sonst wäre sie wahrscheinlich, auch wenn sie immer noch solche Schmerzen hatte,
wahrscheinlich mit Blaulicht gekommen.
Gut, hätte auch wahrscheinlich nicht mehr so viel erzählt.
Ja, das ist so, was ich Ihnen als Rückmeldung geben kann.
Das ist auch so ein bisschen Konzentrationssache.
Das ist zum Ende mit der Sprache dann ein bisschen schwieriger.
Aber eigentlich, das ist eine typische Sache,
die praktisch alle Kollegen und Kolleginnen so haben,
dass das Ananesigespräch noch sehr sprachlich, sehr strukturiert geht.
Und dann beim Arztgespräch ist so ein bisschen der Fluss weg.
Und dann kommen eben diese E's rein.
Das stört so ein bisschen den Gesamteindruck.
Natürlich ist keine Katastrophe, macht es nicht unverständlich.
Aber sollte man versuchen zu vermeiden, bis zum Januar haben Sie ja auch viel Zeit.
Ein bisschen trainieren.
Gut, Dr. Günther, möchten Sie noch etwas sagen?
Ja, nächste Woche, zweimal haben wir noch ein bisschen Zeit.